bueno sabemos que se ha solicitado un
análisis profundo verdad sobre las
causas que están generando este aumento
anual de los feminicidios en perú pero
dada su experiencia quisiera preguntarle
a usted cuáles considera que podrían ser
algunas de esas causas
bueno en realidad la preocupación de la
defensoría tiene que ver con este
problema estructural y una de las causas
es que no se trabaja en la prevención y
en atacar las causas estructurales que
tienen que ver con el machismo que va en
escalada y hay conductas que
van a lacerar la vida de las personas
132 casos representan mujeres que han
estado en un ciclo de violencia muy alto
en su vida y esto tiene que parar pero
no podemos solamente pedir una justicia
efectiva al sistema de sanción de
protección a las mujeres sino que se
trabaje en políticas serias para
prevenir esta esta lacra social de la
violencia en general pero también para
generar condiciones de igualdad y no
discriminación hacia las mujeres
necesitamos que el sistema educativo sea
fuerte que haya políticas claras de
igualdad de género y en eso hay una
responsabilidad de las políticas de
estado
precisamente hacia este punto apunta a
mi próxima pregunta porque desde la
defensoría del pueblo hicieron y hacen
hincapié en la necesidad de tener
políticas públicas direccionadas a esta
problemática cuál es la situación
concreta en perú en este sentido
en realidad en el perú tenemos aprobada
desde el 2019 una política nacional de
igualdad de género tiene planes pero la
defensoría advierte y estamos próximos
emitir un informe sobre las políticas
públicas respecto a la necesidad de que
éstas sean tangibles y tengan resultados
en la vida de las mujeres del perú no
podemos tener normas políticas que estén
aprobadas y ancladas en la
responsabilidad de los poderes del
estado pero que no trasciendan en la
vida de las mujeres ese es el reclamo de
la defensoría para que haya políticas
que sean mucho más fuertes para lograr
una igualdad y no discriminación para
las mujeres una educación
absolutamente respetuosa e igualitaria y
que la violencia como consecuencia de
esas dimensiones vaya disminuyendo en el
país
elena usted hablaba por supuesto de una
violencia estructural verdad pero
quisiera preguntarle si la pandemia y
medidas como el aislamiento pudieron
haber influido en este aumento de los
feminicidios
en realidad el año pasado de crecieron
en algo en el número los feminicidios
pero eso no ha significado que los
índices de feminicidio vayan a disminuir
en el tiempo en este año por eso la
preocupación la pandemia ha develado que
la violencia contra las mujeres ha sido
mucho más brutal porque no había un
sistema que le dé la apertura a las
mujeres no se declaró como un servicio
esencial muchas han sufrido al interior
de sus hogares la violencia extrema si
bien el año pasado hemos cerrado con 138
feminicidios en este año con 132 vemos
que esta cifra se debe elevar entonces
hay medidas que tienen que tomarse
estructuralmente pero también se tienen
que tomar en el contexto de la pandemia
porque la pandemia ha agudizado este
problema y lo lo grave es que la
tolerancia social hacia la violencia
pueda institucionalizarse en nuestro
país